hey youtubers is Charlie thank you to
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Korra Q&A I liked all the
Kyoshi talk after a kuvira crushed that
medal of hers like yo she would have
just absolutely annihilated her she was
kind of stabby earlier in her life but I
think gradually she kind of chilled out
a little bit in case you haven't seen
her last airbender episodes in a while
remember the story about how she fought
off chin the Conqueror and dealt with
the subsequent uprisings in the earth
Kingdom I think they'll be relevant to
the way Korra battles with kuvira
not exactly they're not just like
straight up copying her storyline but I
think it'll be relevant also I know you
guys would be really jazzed to note that
the giveaway this week and next week
will be four copies of the core game I
mean it's a pre-order cuz it's out next
week I'll explain how it's gonna work at
the end of the video but onto questions
so number one tennis ass I get the
feeling kuvira will pull a magneto with
Cora's metal bits if they stay inside
her body yeah I think she's gonna pull
him out herself but not before kuvira
does some magneto on her we do know from
the trailers that at some point Korra is
going to have an army at her back so she
will confront kuvira or at least some
part of the army currently she is unable
to access the Avatar State so she's kind
of weak and as we saw from the pit fight
she's not so hot with earthbending right
now either so even if she doesn't fight
kuvira directly she could still get her
ass handed to her by someone inside the
earth army question number two sozin
asks how do you think the Korra will
reclaim public support from kuvira oh
she's gonna have to get everyone to see
that kuvira is a bad person I think it's
going to have something to do with the
spirit find energy they're trying to
harness they feel very ominous so I feel
like Cora's gonna be able to point to
whatever ends up happening and show
everyone hey kuvira is doing something
that's very terrible do not support her
Frank has already said that Cora's
victory in book 4 isn't going to be tied
to her bending ability like it's not
gonna be a fight to the death
question number three Akira in uzuki
asks do you think that maka convinced Wu
to make a difference I don't think he
completely turned him around with that
one speech but I do think he set him on
the path there's a couple different ways
things could go down at the end of book
4 obviously I think that they'll find
some sort of balance with kuvira like
they're not gonna kill her it's possible
they could turn the earth Kingdom into a
democracy though or
they could do something like England and
give most of his power to a parliament
woo could still end up on the throne but
I don't think it's gonna go back to
being the way things were
question number four no EFS will they
build a nuclear bomb out of the spirit
vines so I at least think they're gonna
use it to power technology at least use
it as batteries way back in book 1 we
did see some of those energy weapons
from future industries like the power
glove that Asami wears it's possible
they'll just use those to juice up the
mechs weapons look for isn't gonna be
super long so I don't think this is
gonna be like some long drawn out
nuclear stalemate or anything like that
but I am interested to see if they do
construct some sort of massive super
weapon question number five
Stevi asks do you think the Boland will
continue to work with kuvira or will he
rejoined team Korra oh yeah of course
I think he's gonna rejoin team Korra I
mean he's drunk the kool-aid at this
point but I think who here is gonna
cross the line at some point and he'll
say you know no no more in the trailer
we do see him running from a mech attack
like he's lava bending his way away from
a mech attack so at some point the metal
army will go after him question number
six combustion woman asks do you think
we'll see Zaheer again I'm not expecting
it but kuvira has been pardoning
criminals are getting president Reiko to
pardon criminals to help her with her
efforts obviously now they've kind of
turned a corner so that might not
continue if he is being kept inside the
earth Kingdom somewhere then she
definitely has access to him but the
White Lotus is guarding him and the
White Lotus doesn't serve kuvira
question number seven Aloha asks do you
think we'll learn who Lynn and soohyun's
father's were I'm not expecting to I'm
actually thinking that they might save
that for the comics I do think
eventually they'll tell that story but
they might do it in the last airbender
comics or eventually whenever they do a
Korra comic they might do it in that I
don't think we're gonna see a whole lot
of extra things that'll take focus away
from team Korra they're the main
characters right now and to deal with
beifong's backstory I think would take a
little bit of focus away that being said
I do hope we get some clues they said
they wrapped all the storylines up in
book four but that doesn't mean that
they answered all the last airbender
questions question number eight is vs do
you think we'll see Omashu not in the
big way we did during Last Airbender
but we do see core inside the Crystal
Caves the green Crystal Caves it's
possible she goes to Omashu to get there
we do see her visiting a white lotus
temple in the trailer that could be
where these clips are from so no
guarantees of will see Omashu but it is
possible i have been surprised at how
earth centric the last two books have
been so i am hoping to see you know a
little bit more of the world but we'll
find out probably the next couple of
episodes question number nine shan asks
do you think Zuko's daughter is gonna
play a major role this season only if
the Fire Nation is involved I mean it's
been very earth centric it's possible we
could go to the Fire Nation at some
point if kuvira turns her attentions to
the Fire Nation like if she starts
taking Fire Nation territory that would
be good cause for Fire Lord scenes there
is like a small part of me though that's
wondering if that one brief shot that we
saw her is all we're ever gonna see that
could be another thing they say for the
comics like explaining who her mother is
question number 10 Alejandra if xiaofu
Falls do you think it'll prompt the
other world leaders to declare war on
kuvira not necessarily I think if she
goes after Republic City it will though
Sallu was just her next target we're
only in the third episode so there's
still a lot of time for her to cause
some damage they explained in the
episode though she controls the metal in
the mines that they need that the other
nations need that's why they don't
declare war right away but thank you so
much everyone for so many questions
these are always a ton of fun to do so
here's the details about the video game
giveaway so for the next two weeks it'll
be just like their normal giveaway but
instead of a gift card it'll just be for
a copy of the core of fighting game it's
out on Tuesday so I will be streaming on
my twitch channel I'm gonna post my
review on this channel of the main
channel emergency awesome but I will
upload the gameplay in the commentary to
my video game channel
that's called Charlie's Dreams if you
guys have never heard of it before yes I
do have a game channel I haven't been
using it a whole lot though there's
links for all that stuff in the
description for the twitch channel in
the video game channel so if you like
video game stuff I'm gonna be doing some
Destiny there tonight too so it'll be a
lot of fun congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner - I am cake you
have an awesome name and now you have a
pre-order for the core game if you've
already ordered it we can work something
out but I'll message you on your channel
for details while we wait next week for
more Toph time click here for my episode
3 video and click here for my top 10
avatar villains thank you so much for
watching so
- I'll see you guys tonight for a
touchscreen